今日1
肇社長です
2日間投稿出来なくてごめんなさい
全然反省してません
28日旧303日間も東京にいて僕は気づいたんですよ
インターネットできる環境がないと動画出せないって思って出せば選手の3日間ごめん
なさい
だけど気づいたらことじゃの後二日間
part 5道しかないということで
今日もバッチリコンビニで働いたんですよ
頑張って年画像を打って
l 地球って
からギグうって
外のゴミ掃除しようと思って外出たら
5人がめっちゃ増えてるんですよ
年末はちょっとみんな浮かれててちょっとクレイジーな奴らが多い気がしますねぇ
ローソンデベロッパーんったらメロンパンの2種類になってたんですよ
これはすごい良い考えですかなと思ったんですけどみんなが好きなサックサックサク
ラップしたメロンバーですこういうのです
あと競ったりしたあのメロンパンっ
こんな感じですこれは中に
あれが入ってるってずるーずメロン果汁が入ってるんですよちょっとメロンメロンパン
でにすでに分かれると思うんですよ
サックサクのクってなるやつとなんか
通じるってなんかこう
はぐじゅっぱなれない対話やはなんか違うんですよねメロンパンっ
ベーコン中途半端な奴がまずいと
すごいことだと思います
ゾンさんじまっ
10 new があると思うんですよ
ています
スコッチから止めます2
わからん
大
あんまりつがいがわからないです
まずは寝てるんですけど
山速乾が全然違いますね
ローソン行ったらメロンパン2つありねあの牛乳がめっちゃ
メロばにゃうんでん
というわけで今日もバイトがあるんで
頑張ってきます
the
ni